between guardians of the galaxy Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame just
about everyone on the planet has gotten
a look at Josh Brolin Asano's but how
they pull the transformation off let's
take a deep dive into how the MCU turned
Josh Brolin into the mad Titan according
to the visual effects supervisor Kelley
ports whose company Digital Domain
worked on creating Thanos for infinity
war the number of people it takes to
complete a major studio movies visual
effects has exploded in recent decades
Marvel's own Iron Man 3 has over 1,800
people credited in his visual effects
Department alone a dramatic step up from
the special effects heavy blockbusters
of decades past port said' to the verge
we were reflecting back on Titanic days
the late 90s where a big effects film
would be considered around 300 shots
whereas infinity war in contrast has
over 3,000 the visual effects shots and
now I am speaking in an interview with
out of the effects Marvel Studios
overall VFX supervisor Dan de Lu gave
some insights into the amount of work
that goes into a movie's visual effects
before anyone's even powered on their
editing break speaking of Avengers
Infinity Ward - Lu said this movie
wasn't grounded like Winter Soldier or
civil war it involved eight to ten foot
tall aliens and battles on other planets
we knew the movie was going to be
massive and had to plan accordingly the
company's plan according to the law
involved dividing up the movie into
individual sequences that would be
awarded to separate VFX houses each
house would get a sequence that would
tell a complete narrative this way each
house could maintain the look and feel
of the sequence were minimizing the need
for shared shots the responsibility of
introducing Thanos to the world in
infinity war was shouldered by Digital
Domain which took on a workload of 513
shots amounting to over 40 minutes of
screen time their work involved bringing
Thanos to life in every scene except the
one on Titan a sequence which was
instead handled by wetted digital well
you might not have heard of the studio's
by name before
you're certainly familiar with their
work we're tourists a studio behind the
Lord of the Rings column and the new
Planet of the Apes movies Caesar while
Digital domains been working in movies
since James Cameron's True Lies in 1994
founded by Cameron and the claim special
effects artist Stan Winston Digital
Domain has been working on large
scale superhero movies since x-men in
2000 and the since had a hand in making
the first Thor the third Iron Man
spider-man homecoming and thor ragnarok
with Marvel Studios even with the team's
extensive experience it took over 340
people from the company nearly two years
to bring just most of Thanos as parts to
fruition which really puts things in the
perspective when it comes to how much
pure labor it takes to make movies of
this scale work directors Anthony and
Joe Russo met with Brolin and the
digital effects artist several months
before live shooting began to both see
what Marvel wanted to accomplish with
the character and also to determine what
the effects companies will be capable of
turning in digital domains Kelly port
said it was a proud moment to show off
digital domains firsts a nose test -
Brolin and the directors on the actors
first day of shooting thought said they
were all very excited about her and I
think there was a collective sigh of
relief that we could pull this off the
results of Digital domains first test
for encouraging showing that the
company's artists were capable of
maintaining Berlin's humanity as they
encases performance in a virtual skin
it's just the way it is I'm not I'm just
a messenger according to dan de Loup
the early tests showed how much we could
do with the character it showed that
wood could take exactly what Berlin did
on stage and reproduce it with the CG
character the test put Brolin at ease
letting the actor know that he didn't
need to oversell his performance to make
the character feel alive as Kelly Porter
I think what was really great about his
reaction was a sense that he did not as
an actor need to overplay the acting
seeing that the effects scene would be
able to effectively translate a lower
key Thanos performance at all of its
subtleties was a boon to the filmmakers
especially Brolin who was worried about
how he would come off an emotion
captured performance no one was more
nervous about bringing Thanos to life
than Josh Brolin playing the mad Titan
wasn't as physically demanding at his
live action performance as cable in
Deadpool 2 but it was emotionally
draining as Brolin described it I was
more nervous doing that than I've been
for a long time
frozen at times found himself having a
hard time striking and imposing presence
while wearing an unflattering motion
capture suit Brolin said you've got to
walk around in a onesie and imagine
yourself as an actor with some impact
I'm sitting there and I'm looking like I
look which is not 700 pounds and purple
and eight feet tall to record Rowland's
performance to production installed
motion
two cameras all around the movie sets
allowing other actors more space to
interact with him the movements of his
body were recorded by those cameras
while close-up shots were recorded by HD
cameras that were attached to a helmet
and pointed back at his face
all the footage was then put into a
massive database with every tiny
movement of Brolin's face being used for
reference when it came time to replace
his features with a computer-generated
Thanos model the goal according to Kelly
port was to have the CG model match the
emotions of the real-life actor port
said we look at the results you look at
Brolin side by side with a nose is he
conveying the same emotional expression
is he conveying the same emotion with
his face and we make a subjective call
one of the more interesting hurdles
overcome in bringing Thanos to life
wasn't making sure that he looked like
Josh Brolin but rather making sure that
he looked liked while himself fans of
the MCU have been anticipating Thanos as
a rival ever since the end of the
Avengers in 2012 when the big purple
space monster first turns with a camera
with a sinister grin this was years
before Brolin was ever cast or
considered for the part in infinity war
so how did the pre-existing Thanos from
prior movies fit into the characters
final form according support the digital
domain team started their Thanos
modeling with the old look and slowly
incorporated Brolin's features there was
no magic to the process just a long back
and forth between their teams and the
people at Marvel both said we try to
find that balance but we did introduce
more of Brolin I think than in previous
Santos's in the films the effects team's
efforts weren't immediately met with
enthusiasm upon the release of the first
footage of Brolin Asano's many fans
criticized the new look finding that too
much a change between the initial and
final versions the most difficult aspect
of bringing Thanos to life had to do
with his quiet reflective moments while
an effects-heavy battle scene has lots
of moving parts from a VFX perspective
it's also easier to cut corners when the
screen is so busy with meteors
explosions and spider-man antics in
other words it's not that hard to make
the purple spaceman fight the big green
guy it's much harder to make you believe
the purple spaceman can cry speaking
with art of the effects kelly port said
the most complicated phonos scene as a
sacrifice of Gamora on for Mia what said
many of the shots of Thanos in the
sequence are very close and very
emotional so it was extremely important
that Brolin's performance come through
for the scene the importance of nailing
planets his ability to physically convey
emotion
can't be overstated one false move and
the filmmakers fall directly into the
uncanny valley once you remember you're
looking at something made in the
computer it's easy to be taken out of
the story you'd basically be watching
Jar Jar Binks cry and there's nothing
engrossing about that well the idea of
getting into such a pivotal mode cap
role was daunting a Brolin has since
gone on to call Thanos quote one of the
most favorite jobs I've ever heard part
of getting into the character involved
immersing himself in nearly 50 years
worth of Marvel Comics history of course
Marvel Studios didn't just send a Brolin
to the local comic book shop with a gift
card
according to Brolin they sent me over
this Bible just all this information it
was a massive thing and yet even that
was maybe 1/16 of what there was to
learn as anyone who's ever read comic
books as well aware the internal
consistency of the characters and their
stories can sometimes be a nightmare
especially as characters mutate across
decades and the different writers the
comic book and Marvel world it's not
only extremely emotional to people but
so in death there's no way to learn it
all but you try to do what you can I
started reading and I was in awe the
cliche goes the eyes are windows to the
soul which is really just a way of
saying they convey subtle day they
squint or widen to show fear shock or
focus conveying emotion through tiny
micro expressions and when it comes to a
monstrously evil figure like Thanos
seeing those emotions can make all the
difference according to Anthony Russo
who co-directed infinity war and endgame
even though he's despicable on so many
levels there's a part of Thanos sighs
very empathetic he has a very complex in
a life and he's not all bad the
filmmaker also called Josh Brolin a
performer who's capable of delivering
that kind of complexity where you have
that level of violence in him but at the
same time you have that level of
sensitivity all of Berlin's acting work
will be for nothing if Digital Domain
proved incapable of mapping Berlin's
face onto a monster but fortunately the
studio was up to the task
according to port what we really focus
on is the eyes at Digital Domain and
there's a ton of work and a huge amount
of detail around that the company
doesn't treat the eye as one object but
rather as layers of intersecting objects
making the final product feel more
complex and the life all of this goes a
long way toward making Thanos feel like
a real person and that realism in turn
makes him so much scarier another one of
the tricky parts of animating a CGI
character has to do with making the
audience believe the character actually
exists on the game
plain azrael actors the most important
element to focus on in this aspect is
lighting
according to ports if the lighting is
not good it won't look photo-real a CGI
character starts off being lit by
nothing when the character is placed
into real-world footage that saturated
with a certain kind of lighting a lack
of similar lighting on the CGI model
will look disastrous speaking to art of
the effects Port Said as we began to
experiment of lighting ideas we soon
discovered that Thanos looked his best
for slightly more complex lighting with
various colors rather than monochromatic
light many of the scenes Digital Domain
was tasked with it took place in darker
settings and spaceships or stormy
planets giving the team some flexibility
when it came to lighting fellows his
skin for the scene when Thanos arrives
on earth in broad daylight they had to
contend with making him look like he was
being lit by the same sunshine as a
performer's Port Said we found that
having Thanos walk through the dappled
light of the trees was very effective
for integrating him to the shots and
giving him depth the years of work paid
off with Infinity Ward's debut during an
interview conducted after the movie's
release port said the excitement of the
audience's reaction seeing the film for
the first time was really really cool
for me we do it for the love of the
craft but we also do it for the love of
entertaining the reception from the
audience is so rewarding it means a lot
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite Marvel movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]